[Music]
okay my assignment for that is to
complete my own survey I have to do
really fast so I'm just gonna start I'll
read you know he can capture their know
Katherine for about nine years now which
is by my reckoning a very long time I've
known myself for as long as itself knows
itself but yes I'm Katherine I want
nothing more than what she gives for me
I want maybe a little bit more
self-restraint and a Nintendo Wii what
are you doing I'm making a brotherhood
2.0 video which is part of the
Brotherhood 2.0 project which is a weird
thing that I'm doing with my Brotherhood
involves posting a lot of video blogs on
the Internet
I'm also running eco kicker org which is
a blog for environmental technologies
and I'm running my old web designer
development business and I'm also trying
to be a freelance writer look I'm in
this month's edition of Mental Floss
hell you can be doing it well the video
blog is another 11 months yikes I'll
probably be doing web development for
the rest of my life and I hope to be
writing for about that long - what do
you want be like pretty much exact what
I'm doing which is really lucky and
amazing and for the first time I've ever
been able to say that what's that can
you like hopefully you know Peyman
fortune but probably content and
obscurity are you doing up to this point
of kind of with my life just going to
the flow you know whichever way but now
this time my life II feel like I've got
a paddle and I'm beating bad people over
the head with it
that's better here I hate this question
um serious fiction the memory of
whiteness for funny fiction going postal
for nonfiction last child in the woods
it's gonna put a gate oh my god I have
to be really quick wake up and check my
email and discover that I've become
famous for something that I did that's
really interesting and really cool and
I'm really proud of go have a nice poop
go to the beach where it is warm and
sunny and Kathryn is wearing a bikini
bull hiking by a cool mountain stream
then for lunch have something that I've
never had before but which is amazingly
good it's been some time surfing which I
have never done before but am suddenly
extremely good at eat a late dinner at
the red bird restaurant in Montana walk
out the front door and find that
everyone I know is having a block party
in the alley behind the Florence hotel
join them soon all things come to an end
how will humans go extinct I actually
think I'm an optimist when it comes
people going extinct I think we will
eventually tire of procreation and find
new ways of existing that don't involve
mass slaughters and resource depletion
you cannot get to these days well
there's a lot of cute ones around and I
like them but they drool a lot and I
really really really really really don't
wanna get one myself
pull your own question enjoy this is a
question that I never asked because I
can never find an answer do it myself
but this year I can what's the best song
you heard this year far and away Weird
Al's white and nerdy
better than if you give it on oh my god
that's a taste better than anything else
what does it wrote that tastes like ah
like a hot dog with a stick in it dipped
in some corn batter and then and like
deep-fry wait no oh never mind I do a
cliche what can be either absent-minded
professor or kid in a candy store which
is pretty much how I feel when I'm in
the zone on the Internet
so maybe absent-minded kid in the candy
store what should we take a part of it
get a day almost invariably getting out
of bed dude I have ticket yes yes yes
yes yes it's justice yes
kita Pacolet chocolate because it's more
advanced it's more difficult it's more
new and fresh in complex well you look
it up anyway under the sea darling it's
better down where it's wetter take it
from me yeah or maybe Mars or maybe in a
small town in Montana or maybe in a
small town of the southeastern United
States as long as all my friends were
there okay I checked the b-52s excited
until again super successful like this
would be definitely a magazine about
environment technologies because if my
business was instantly successful then
not be really great industry a
contractor Billie time travel I don't
believe anybody said invisibility
because time travel is you can
definitely do everything that you can do
with a disability and more as long as I
don't have any chances of ripping shreds
in space-time Continuum's well an under
abundance of katherines
so yeah definitely overpopulation to
many people but I really don't want
everybody to die so I'm thinking we
should lay the blame someplace else like
like brains hardwired for a local
concern in a world with global
consequences that one sounds good
am i like absolutely done the service
section in this video is only three
minutes and 27 seconds you can time it
so don't go telling me that I didn't
complete the challenge just because this
video is longer than three minutes and
30 seconds frosty on Monday
I've submitted an uncompleted version of
this survey to the comments of all the
different places where you might find
this video all of our viewers who made
this challenge up for me I would like to
invite you to complete the survey
yourselves so text-based forum in a
video form and whatever form you like or
not at all
that's fine too but I wanted to give you
the chance in case you wanted to also so
you can decipher it if you can quite
understand what that chipmunk is hand